Do you get annoyed with your partner
for always wanting to go out and start golfing without you
he's always talking golf wants to practice his swing
whatever it may be
hear me out ladies
A prime example of “if you can't beat join them”
You might suck at golfing (at first)
I’ve never been good at golfing
a lot of time I wouldn't make contact at all
honestly I would just swing
and then where am I where's the ball
right there I would look like a silly buffoon
but that never stopped me from persistently trying to get better
up until two weeks ago you wanna know what happened?
I got better
it’s so addicting when you finally figure something out
now I understand why the men are so obsessed with golf
I'm obsessed now I want to get better
I want to learn I wanna get out there on the golf course
not only that it's really good to be out in nature
also it's a really fun activity to do with your man
my man is always begging for me to go golfing with him
I thought it was boring because I didn’t wanna just sit in the golf cart
I don't just sit in the golf cart anymore
now I'm out there learning how to swing
he's helping me and it's just so much fun
here's your sign ladies
if you can't beat them join them!